[Musique]
admettez généreux puis il avait
confiance dont l'humanité puisse me fier
pas de gens tout il vous ne se vend pas
le père armand atos yann est décédé en
après une carrière prolifique pendant
laquelle certains de ses tableaux ont
atteint des prix considérables je vois
sur internet que les tableaux souvent
pour de sommeil trois formes et cent
mille cinquante mille soixante mille
malgré ces prix de vente élevé lorsqu
armenta social est hospitalisé en 2007 à
la suite d'un accident vasculaire
cérébral
sa soeur mary découvre qu'il est ruiné
c'est nous qui devait payer pour que ce
bail qui n'avait ni des cartes
d'identité les portefeuilles ni argent
ils étaient complètement vidées mérite à
tossiat y apprend que depuis des années
son frère ne touche qu'un faible
pourcentage du prix de vente de ses
toiles se touche ok je te bouges plus je
ne croyais pas c'est pierre antoine
tremblay propriétaire de la galerie 2000
à montréal qui étaient là gendarmes en
atos jan mais huit atos yens l'accusent
d'avoir exploité son frère d'habitude en
juin contre les deux personnes gagnent
quelque chose étant le contrat je vois
seulement que se tromper qu'ils gagnent
mérite attention veut faire invalider le
contrat qui liait les deux hommes et
récupérer tous les droits d'auteur sur
l'oeuvre de son frère pierre antoine
tremblay jure qu'il n'a rien à se
reprocher au contraire trouvez moi un
gerald galerie d'un artiste au canada
depuis 400 ans
que fait le travail que j'ai fait sur ta
tâche a aucun qui dit vrai notre enquête
sur tâte ostiane nous a fait découvrir
certains des aspects les moins nobles du
marché de l'art
[Musique]
armand atesyan était un peintre canadien
d'origine arménienne
il a connu un début de carrière
fulgurant et l'exposé plus partout dans
le monde
il allait il voyageait souvent et
l'aller en europe aux etats unis à new
york tout partout le canada au début des
années 70 c'est le galeriste montréalais
bernard des roches qui s'occupe de la
carrière d'armand atos yann sa nièce
brigitte des roches qui est aujourd'hui
propriétaire d'une galerie d'art se
souvient des débuts du peintre armand
comme une vedette il était très jeune
plein de talent sous doués armenta
social a 17 ans quand il fait sa
première exposition solo à new york un
critique d'art compare son talent à
celui de van go et de monnaie à 22 ans
armenta social devient le plus jeune
peintre admis au sein de l'académie
royale des arts du canada
le fait que thatcher a été nommé à
l'académie
à cette époque le 1.6 jeunes pour vous
ce qu'ils étaient un cran peinte en
devenir pendant les 20 ans de son
association avec bernard des roches
armenta sociale gagne très bien sa vie
il touche environ 50% du prix de vente
de ses oeuvres
mais les deux hommes se brouillent et en
2001 armand atesyan signe un premier
contrat d'exclusivité avec le marchand
d'art pierre antoine tremblay la
réputation de l'homme n'est pourtant pas
sans tache
depuis 20 ans il a été mêlé à plus de
160 poursuites civiles
il vient de fermer sa galerie d'art mais
faire et de faire une faillite
personnelle à tossiat n'est au courant
mais décide de faire le saut quand même
c'est un genre là lui a fait beaucoup de
promesses
il a dit qu' ils veulent les faire
beaucoup d exposition qu'il va très
femme il va l'amener au guggenheim tout
autour du monde qui il allait tout ton
amusé on est en novembre 2001 les
attentats du world trade center viennent
de se produire et les deux hommes ont un
grand projet d'exposition sur new york
dans cette vidéo tournée à l'époque
pierre antoine tremblay prévoit une
tournée internationale
[Musique]
mais nous sommes en guerre contre tout
le monde pensait que armand oui il
mettait tout seul dans mon panier mais
c'était le panier qu'ils le sortent et
dans le monde international
c'est le deuxième tableau le nu est le
deuxième tableau que j'ai acheté bras
gauche était l'ami et le principal
collectionneurs des oeuvres d'art mandat
social pendant plusieurs années comme ça
j'ai connu sa maison est un véritable
musée pour le père je rends compte qu'on
se rencontre
parce que chaque jour je travaille juste
à côté de sa maison
je voyais tout ce qu'il faisait il y
avait des tableaux magnifiques
c'est en 2004 avec une exposition
intitulée les géants de montréal
carreman à tossiat n'atteint l'un des
sommets traque arrière à l'époque
personne ne se doute qu'ils ne touchent
qu'un très faible pourcentage du prix de
vente suggéré de ses toiles je pensais
qu'il touchait le bon montant jamais
pensé qu'elle touchait presque rien de
ce qu'il faisait
on pensait que amant gagner beaucoup
d'argent puis qu'il le gaspiller
lorsqu'arnaud associatons balader cesse
de perdre en 2007
c'est sa soeur mary qui prend ses
affaires en main elle obtient le dernier
contrat qui lie son frère à pierre
antoine tremblay et découvrent qu'ils ne
touchent que 5 % du prix de vente
suggéré de ses toiles
125 $ pour un tableau de 10 pouces par
douze prix de détail suggéré 3300
dollars 600 $ pour un temps de parc
harry reid vente suggéré 11900 dollars
1500 $ pour 1 60 ares 60 prix de vente
suggéré par pierre antoine tremblay 30
2900 $ en plus le contrat implique 40
atos yann doit offrir toutes ses toiles
à pierre antoine tremblay pendant dix
ans au même prix ça change pas alors le
marché peut changer les tableaux le
valeur augmenter mais le prix qu'une
piémont fleuve ne change pas mais ce qui
fait déborder le vase c'est qu'en plus
des prix très bas
armand atos yann cèdent tous ses droits
d'auteur et de reproductions à pierre
antoine tremblay selon les avocats que
nous avons consulté les contrats qu'il y
est associée année tremblay était
défavorable à l'artiste abusif voire
immoraux mais ils n'étaient pas illégaux
ce que j'étais prête à lui payer à cette
époque le rct saut ça pesait son affaire
puis d'une façon d'un os de l'argent
n'avait vraiment aucune importance
thatta samedi à flipper les choisit
d'ameuter en avait qu'un en aurait eu
cent fois plus leur et flipper pareil
pierre antoine tremblay justifie ses
prix très bas de diverses façons
il affirme entre autres qu'il dépense
est quasiment tous ses profits pour
promouvoir et diffuser l'oeuvre de
l'artiste
une exposition aujourd'hui ça coûte
minimum 75 dollars on parle de grande
exposition parle pas de tournoi outre en
marge avec deux verres de vin
puis vint invités qui sont toujours les
mêmes les géniales montréal je déplaçais
mille personnes les ministres et
ambassadeurs de 171 pays en crise et
c'est ça c'est du jamais vu s'est pas
arriver dans vie de riopelle c'est pas
arrivé dans la vie de bord du lot c'est
pas ruminer dans le mittelland danville
le mieux alors qui doit payer pour ça
c'est moi qui paye pour ça est il normal
de donner autour de 5 % du prix de vente
suggéré à un artiste parce qu'on vend et
qu'on fait connaître son oeuvre
nous avons posé la question à marie
france lamoureux propriétaire d'une
galerie d'art depuis une trentaine
d'années c'est très très beau lancer
même très très bas parce que
habituellement quand un agent achète
toute la production d'un artiste d'avant
ce tout ce qui va pas une drogue dans
l'année courante
les chiffres se situent entre 20 et 38 %
du prix de détails de l'oeuvre en bas de
ça c'est abusé de l'artiste l'os est
hors norme ce n'est pas quelque chose
que j'ai jamais vue sur 128 a lancé
c'est hors norme
l'autre argument de pierre antoine
tremblay s'est clairement à tossiat
n'était en déclin lorsqu'il est devenu
son agent la socialite complètement
désuète personne en veut aller voir les
prix des enchères à cette époque là vous
allez voir que je ne paye plus cher que
le prix des enchères
alors s'il veut vendre ses tableaux il
voit tout juste pensé par des engins
parce qu'il ya plus personne car buts à
tottenham
les recherches effectuées par la galerie
ce de marie france lamoureux démontre
plutôt le contraire
monsieur tato ça n'était pas désuet en
98 2000 2001 monsieur tato saad
c'est toujours bien vendu et
il a commencé à briser ses propres
records au niveau de la vente dans les
années quatre-vingt dix-huit olympique
à ce moment là que s'est fait ensuite de
ce début 2001 envers et contre tout
pierre antoine tremblay maintien qu'ils
paient le juste prix
aujourd'hui je fais de l'argent avec ta
tâche année à cette époque les gens
faisaient pas parfait c'est pas plus que
tu as à pierre antoine tremblay estime
que de 2001 à 2007
galerie de mêlée lui même fait un profit
d'environ un million de dollars sur
l'oeuvre de tassos jan selon notre
évaluation
malgré des dépenses de promotion
importante le profit aurait plutôt été
d'au minimum 6 millions de la tat ociane
quant à lui aurait fait un proxy après
dépenses d'environ 400 mille dollars
ces quinze fois moins d'argent pour
l'artiste que pour l'argent
dans le milieu des arts visuels montréal
est quasiment tout le monde connaît
pierre antoine tremblay l'homme a
souvent fait les manchettes à cause de
ses nombreuses poursuites judiciaires il
a aussi fait scandale en 2003 lorsque
loto québec et la société des alcools du
québec l'ont accusée de leur avoir vendu
de nombreux tableaux à des prix bien au
delà de leur valeur
les deux affaires se sont réglées par
des ententes confidentielles
pierre antoine tremblay a une façon bien
à lui de faire des affaires par exemple
au cours de notre enquête
plusieurs personnes nous ont dit qu'ils
avaient tendance à déclarer faut des
tableaux de kato cian qu'il y aurait
échappé afin de vérifier ce qu'il en
était nous avons tenté une expérience
mérite atos yann nous a prêté ce tableau
que son frère lui aurait donné en cadeau
il va vous dire que c'est un faux j'en
suis sûr et certain
incognito
nous nous sommes rendus à la galerie
2000 propriété de pierre antoine
tremblay bonjour
pour lui montrer le tableau en tableau à
la réaction a été instantané ce tableau
n'est pas imaginable d'attention ni
comme action qui fait fini le sujet
parce que les tons jour dont ses 45
heures sont toutes à l'onu un tableau de
natation 12 heures des histoires de
vrais tableaux déclaré faut nous en
avons entendu plusieurs entre autres
celle du marchand d'art claude cours
s'ils s'étaient tous les vendredis
prochaine partie de la journée avec lui
il y avait trop 7,8 tableau a à m'offrir
au début des années 2000
armand à tossiat n'a vendu de nombreux
tableaux a clos pour 6 en cachette de
pierre antoine tremblay claude courcy
jure qu'il ne savait pas que tu as
tossiat n'avait signé un contrat
d'exclusivité
je les aient péri en 2004 qu'un j'ai
reçu ni en dames à une mise en demeure
de pierre antoine tremblay qui indique
qu'il est strictement interdit d'acheter
directement toute oeuvre d'art mandat
social j'avais été complètement acheter
sauf que j'en avais beaucoup beaucoup en
réserve claude cours s'ils décident de
liquider sa collection
il veut une dizaine de tatsiana la
galerie d'art perron de québec et
quelques mois plus tard téléphone sonne
c'est à nantes est haussier
y est autant plaire je dis que ce qui se
passe et digital à québec puis les
tableaux que te vendu apéro je viendrai
déclare défaut on m'oblige aider dit
claire les fours armenta tossiat
n'aurait dit à claude courcy que c'est
pierre antoine tremblay qui l'a obligé à
faire la fausse déclaration
nous avons mis la main sur un
enregistrement dans lequel on l'entend
admettre sa pause déclarations et laissé
entendre qu'elle n'a été faite que par
la crainte de son agent pourquoi après
cet incident pour se protéger claude
course et prend une photo d'armand avec
chacun des tableaux qu'il a acheté il
utilise ensuite les photos comme preuve
d'authenticité
je prends deux tableaux que je mets à
l'anc 1 une banque aux enchères à
toronto
les tableaux et les photos d'armes en
tête aussi avec les tableaux mais
l'histoire se répète
l'encanteur m'appelle pour me dire car
mercato si vous n'êtes déclaré les
tableaux n'étant pas sonné pierre
antoine tremblay nie toute
responsabilité dans chacune de ces
affaires pour vous forcer à passer en
adopte le dernier joe intéresse les âges
car dalle de fouchy de marché chez moi
et pourquoi tu atassi en face à
ces histoires de fo ont tous moins eu un
effet positif pour pierre antoine
tremblay ses compétiteurs ont cessé
d'acheter des tableaux dans son dos j'ai
tout vendu
j'ai jamais racheté de tête haussier
jamais j'avais tout chevet d'un tableau
tâte aussi les jeux récemment dans le
milieu des arts claude courcy n'est pas
le seul qui préfère se tenir loin de ta
sociale et de pierre antoine tremblay
les gens sont dit stop aux magouilles à
yema l'âne est un épisode a fait de la
réputation comme changer ce système vous
évoluez dans les milieux vous bousculer
les habitudes des plus grandes galeries
au canada ces gens là son premier ami
puis j'en ai rien à cirer sérieux je
n'en ai rien à cirer
mon coeur est clair ma vie est clair la
dernière poursuites en cours impliquant
pierre antoine tremblay a été déposée
par un homme d'affaires américain
entre 2009 et 2011
en guise d'investissement randy ferbey a
acheté plusieurs toiles d'art mandat
social via pierre antoine tremblay manif
estime qu'il a été victime de fausses
représentations dans sa poursuite
il affirme ce père antoine tremblay lui
a vendu des toiles en lui disant que la
santé de tat ossiam se dégradent est et
qu'il allait bientôt mourir
encore une fois pierre antoine tremblay
nie les allégations
y avez vous dit que la valeur des
tableaux tata sienne qu'il avait à les
tripler en six mois après ça m'arrive
pour se préparer sans le cadre de sa
poursuite
randy ferbey a embauché la galeriste
marie france lamoureux pour faire une
évaluation de la valeur marchande de ces
tableaux
elle estime qu'ils valent aujourd'hui la
moitié de ce qu'il a payé
maintenant 2013 nous sommes arrivés avec
une bracket pour l'ensemble de ses sites
ce tableau leur hand 64000 et 74 mille
dollars
vous me dites que payer 124 mille trois
cents alors oui c'est à peu près 50% de
la valeur que lui aurait payé à ce
moment là il semblerait que les
allégations de prix gonflés les rumeurs
de faux et les tensions entre pierre
antoine tremblay et la famille d'armand
atos yann ont fait chuter la cote de
l'artiste depuis quelques années les
collectionneurs ont commencé à être un
peu frileux à moins croire alors ça fait
chuter les prix ça fait chuter les
demandes et c'est très dommage parce que
ça n'enlève pas la qualité des oeuvres
de monsieur pathos jan
comment une personne comme ça peut avoir
trois galeries avec 700 éthiques
n'importe qui peut ouvrir une galerie
d'art aucune formation n'est obligatoire
aucun code d'éthique ne s'applique pour
pallier cela le regroupement des
artistes en arts visuels et
l'association des galeries d'art
contemporain du québec viennent tout
juste de publier un contrat type est un
guide des meilleures pratiques qui
devrait mieux baliser à l'avenir les
relations entre galeristes et artistes
de son côté pierre antoine tremblay
persiste et signe
qu'est ce que vous répondez pour des
tracts à l'accumulation fait une
réputation
par contre si j'avais rien fait dans la
vie personne par whedon mois
il y à fort à parier que nous n'avons
pas fini d'entendre parler de pierre
antoine tremblay j'écris ma vie au
complet je vais approcher fabienne
larouche pour faire une mini série à la
télévision pour vraiment que les gens
comprennent
je suis parce que je ne peux pas être le
cocu rotin fait pour le milieu d'art
puis de pourrait passer pour le probant
du milieu.dans
[Musique]